[Musique]
bonjour christian jacob
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
ce matin vous êtes président du parti l
air vous êtes avec nous au lendemain
d'un bureau politique très attendu très
commentée on va entrer dans le détail de
ce que vous avez annoncé disons que en
gros vous avez fait hier un petit pas ou
un pas vers la primaire sauf que dans la
foulée xavier bertrand a été très clair
écoutez le il était l'invité hier soir
du journal de 20 heures sur tf1
je suis candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
je suis candidat pour être président de
la république et c'est une candidature
de cohérence cohérence avec ma
conception d'élection présidentielle
c'est une rencontre entre un homme une
femme et les français et aussi cohérence
par rapport à tout ce que j'ai déclaré
depuis des mois et des mois
depuis le premier jour j'ai joué la
carte de la vérité et de la transparence
en indiquant que si j'étais élu à la
tête de ma région je serai candidat à
l'élection présidentielle et donc en
cohérence
je ne serai pas candidat aux primaires
voilà c'est clair c'est net il le répète
il ne sera pas candidat à la primaire il
vous envoyer aux pelotes dans le fond un
bp un peureux politique pour rien
non non pas du tout pas du tout
au contraire je pense qu'il était
important d'abord après les
départementales et les régionales de
tenir ce bureau politique
je rappeler que depuis 20 mois la droite
s'est totalement reconstruite
on a après avoir encaissé les échecs que
l'on sait on a gagné de manière très
large les municipales n'a gagné les
sénatoriales
on a gagné les législatives partielles
on a gagné les départementales on a
gagné les régionales
et pourquoi on l ce résultat parce que
on a su le faire dans une famille
politique apaisée dans l'union c'est ça
qui nous a permis de gagner pas autre
chose et pour la présidentielle il en
est de même
je suis convaincu aujourd'hui très
clairement la droite est en situation de
gagner la présidentielle mais elle ne
pourra le faire que dans l'union et donc
j'appelle tout le monde au rassemblement
on va y venir vous allez nous dire
comment m'enfin comme quand on entend de
la vie et bertrand les français ils
entendent nous le disent mais c'est
quand même un gros caillou dans la
chaussure de l air il joue cavalier seul
il prend de l'avancé pendant que vous
procrastiner pardon lui va avancer
on a avancé ensemble dans dans sa région
aujourd'hui si xavier bertrand et
président de région et qu'il est très
largement élu il est grâce au soutien et
avec les équipes les républicains qui
sont d'ailleurs majoritaire dans ses
livres moi même je suis allé le soutenir
chez lui tout seul on le sait bien et on
sait tous qu'on ne peut gagner
qu'ensemble et et xavier bertrand a trop
d'expérience politique pour savoir que
seul il ne peut pas gagner on a besoin
d'être rassemblée
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
aurons on a fixé un calendrier avec un
point le 25 septembre prochain bus que
là nous aurons un congrès et à ce moment
là on a trois mois et pendant ces trois
mois je pense que tout le monde
tout le monde va se voir se parler
échanger voir effectivement si on
construit non pas une primaire la
primaire on a vu les échecs il y avait
en 2016 a parlé d'un processus de
rassemblement parce que l'objectif c'est
ça c'est se rassembler
ça n'est pas d'avoir un vainqueurs et
des vaincus et que le vainqueur oui
les vaincus ça n'est pas ça qu'il faut
être rassemblés dès maintenant et même
au delà vous espérez que les égouts
s'efface derrière l'intérêt général oui
c'est ce que je dis ah parce que c'est
ce que j'ai dit hier mot pour mot vous
avez quand même quatre ténors de la
droite et pas n'importe lesquels des
présidents de région reconduit avec
parfois des scores tout à fait
spectaculaire qui vous qui ont écrit une
tribune pour dire il nous faut une
primaire c'est le système le plus
démocratique qui soit pour qu'on élise
notre désigne notre champion oui ça
c'est une décision que ne prendront pas
ça se prend pas fait vous faites voter
hier un processus qui au contraire
semble-t-il évite au maximum d'arriver à
la primaire oui parce que ce n'est pas
d'hier c'est pas trois ou quatre
personnes qui sur un coin de table
décide des choses moi je suis à la tête
d'un parti politique d'une famille nous
avons des militants d'ailleurs avec une
très grosse progression par rapport à
l'année dernière et donc on aura ce
choix cette décision à prendre le 25
septembre en congrès en connaissance de
cause d'ici là il y a trois mois et
pendant ces trois mois tout le monde va
se parler se voir et on sait une chose
tous ceux que vous avez cités mais aussi
beaucoup d'autres et xavier bertrand
aussi c'est qu'on ne peut gagner que
dans l'union
aucun ne peut gagner seul aucun sais
quelle que soit nommée quel que soit le
talent des uns et des autres la
démonstration vous savez les municipales
ça n'était pas un parcours de santé
rappelez vous au lendemain des
européennes
on nous annonçait raz-de-marée du front
national c'est un effondrement du front
national aux régionales en 2015 ya six
ans il était en tête dans six régions de
france au premier tour
là ils sont arrivés dans une seule
région de france ils ont perdu plus de
100 conseillers régionaux
il était présent dans 14 départements
ils ne sont plus que dans huit donc la
droite aujourd'hui un vrai chemin pour
gagner mais elle ne le peut le faire que
dans le mur et si on a gagné les
départementales et les régionales c'est
pour ça et je sais que les uns et les
autres ont du bon sens et on va encore
une fois voire trois mois pour
construire sa mère a entendu les oui
mais j'entends tout le monde
non pas parce que je suis allé le
soutenir chez lui comme les souvenirs
des autres dont vous l'avez entendu tout
et pas une seconde de sa détermination
donc ça veut dire quoi que les autres
les autres présidents de régions doivent
se mettre derrière lui à la
détermination c'est un élément essentiel
pour gagner mais ça peut enfermer aussi
on a besoin d'être à la fois déterminé
mais d'être rassembleur parce que si la
détermination continue enfin quoi
constituer ou permet enfin fait aboutie
plus trop pardon c'est sûr je vais
mourir et la nuit je cherche mais si ça
amène à se mettre d ailleurs et des
boules quiès c'est pas une bonne chose
il faut être déterminé c'est une qualité
mais il faut être rassembleur et si on
n'est pas maçon il est pas on ne les a
pas il ne l'est pas suffisamment à
l'évidence puisqu'il dit mettez vous
derrière tout ça va se construire encore
une fois les régionales il n'y a pas été
tout seuls sans les élèves n'auraient
pas gagné
ces régionales il le sait parfaitement
attention tout le monde a besoin de tout
le monde
jean leonetti vous vous allez faire en
sorte donc vous allez essayer de faire
en sorte qu'ils s'entendent
ça voudrait dire que par exemple en
termes programmatique il ya une espèce
de deals d'accord entre eux laurent
wauquiez comme un grand responsable de
la droite et xavier bertrand où ils vont
faire un programme commun sur le d'abord
sur le programme c'est le travail que
nous avons fait depuis 18 mois aux
républicains c'est plus de 200 réunions
c'est une douzaine de conventions et là
nous sommes en train de mettre en forme
ce ce programme et ce projet avec
l'ensemble des propositions sur le
travail de fond le corpus idéologique
il est constitué et aujourd'hui le
corpus idéologique et les portait
justement parce qu'ils ont préparée par
les républicains j'ai pas entendu
d'idées géniales à droite venant
d'ailleurs tout vient du travail qui a
été réalisé et il n'y a pas aujourd'hui
je ne sens pas de différence idéologique
profonde entre les uns et les autres
vous savez si on parle immigration si on
parle sécurité
si on parle endettement si on parle
solidarité
si on parle
sentez vous allez m'expliquer où sont
les différences entre les différentes
personnalités que vous venez de citer
gamma pas j'en attends parfois leurs
gammes pelletier qui d'ailleurs oui en
fait c'était pas ça le jeu le sujet
c'était déclaration tient absolument pas
c'étaient les déclarations qui est qui
qui l'avait fait à propos de la
proximité ou la possibilité de
travailler avec avec monsieur ménard
c'était le fait sur le plan économique
de position personnelles qui sont
d'ailleurs tout à fait respectable mais
quand on est numéro deux il faut aussi
tenir une ligne à une barrière pour moi
qui est très claire jamais aucun accord
de quelque nature que ce soit avec le
front national jamais et de la même
façon que jamais emmanuel macron ne sera
notre candidat caf a tant que je serai
président des républicains
enfin le test suivant quand vos
questions un ténor de la droite qui
quand même à l'instar de guillaume
pelletier aujourd'hui ce dirais-je moi
je soutiens untel ou untel ou untel vous
dit non
ce soir je pose problème ce bris en
attendant mais ne se posent pas de
problème chaque alien chacun est libre
de se l arrêt de ses choix vous savez il
y en a ou citer xavier bertrand il y en
a beaucoup d'autres aussi qui a par
bruno retailleau et candidat aujourd'hui
il déclaré bah j'ai cru comprendre que
laurent wauquiez réfléchissait j'ai cru
comprendre que valérie pécresse y
réfléchit ça et peut-être les gendarmes
il ya sort sur el mechri charnier se
sont sérieusement exactement donc vous
voyez sont pas encore candidat officiel
mettant non mais ça n'a rien à voir sont
des candidats potentiels intéressants
voilà mais ça n'a rien à voir avec le
front national et la république en bas
quel rôle ont joué les sondages les
enquêtes dans le travail que vous menez
là on va lancer une grande enquête qui
d'ailleurs je crois n'a jamais été lancé
par un parti politique sur un
échantillon très large plus de 15000
personnes à la fois sur les thématiques
les attentes des français ce qu'ils
attendent du président de la république
est également sur les différents
candidats potentiels la capacité à
rassembler la capacité à incarner les
territoires
la capacité à positionner à faire
rayonner l'image de la france donc c'est
tout ce travail que nous allons faire
sous l'autorité scientifique de pascal
perrineau qui est long à l'ancien
directeur du cevipof et l'enquète sera
faite par l'ifo donc c'est plutôt sur le
contenu des attentes passion et aussi
aussi bas les personnalités sur mon site
et sur leur capacité justement à
répondre c'est à ce que vous savez
venant de vous c'est vrai que ça peut
étonner parce que vous vous souvenez
mieux personne de la bataille balladur
chirac en 95 jusque très tard les
sondages donnaient edouard balladur
gagnant donc les sondages est ce que
c'était un epa on n'est pas on n'est pas
sur un sondage on est sur une enquête et
vous êtes bien différent une enquête
d'opinion très large à la fois ceux des
critères qualitatifs et ceux des
critères quantitatifs
vous savez c'est en effet une primaire
et j'étais toujours à des soutiens du
premier au dernier jour de jacques
chirac on aurait fait une primaire
chirac l'aurait perdu donc c'est pas ça
le sujet sujet c'est la sincérité un
moment la rencontre avec avec les
français mais simplement et on a besoin
d'avoir tous les moyens encore une fois
l'union ça ne se décrète pas à la
schlague ça se construit ça se construit
dans le temps et ça se construit en
étant le plus ouvert possible et donc
d'où l'intérêt de cette enquête
d'opinion qui n'est pas un élément de
décision mais qui est un élément
d'éclairage met donc dans le fond vous
êtes toujours opposé à la primaire mais
pas changé de continent jamais considéré
que c'était bon et alors une fois n'est
pas coutume il ya une personne sur
twitter qui voyant que vous étiez invité
ce matin à poser cette question vous la
pause peut-il dire clairement christian
jacob qu'une primaire ouverte de la
droite et du centre est enterré une
primaire ouverte
non non elle n'est pas enterrée on a
trois mois donc on va pas se précipiter
vous savez l'histoire de la vème
république et la déclaration des
candidatures
sans remonter très loin jacques chirac
annonce sa candidature le 4 novembre
à l'époque tous les éditorialistes a
expliqué que c'était beaucoup trop de
nous et on voyait pas pourquoi il se
déclarait ce moment là nicolas sarkozy
annonce sa candidature le 29 novembre
françois fillon à l'investiture le 30
novembre
donc c'est pour le mois de novembre on
est début juillet donc on va avoir un
peu de sang froid le calme des vieilles
troupes et on va avancer d'accord donc
il y aura une primaire un tour ou non il
ya la possibilité non non ce sont les
militants je vous ai dit le 25 septembre
on a trois mois le 25 septembre les
mutants décideront on aura à ce moment
là il y aurait eu six effectuons et s'il
ya une prime eu l'air aussi en est s'il
y en a pas s'ils n'en veulent pas ils
deviennent primaire et de quels
processus de rassemblement n'utilise on
verra l'attendait on est début juillet
le 25 septembre il ya un calendrier qui
est très précis et donc à ce moment là
les militants effectivement auront le
choix soit de maintenir les statuts tels
qu'ils sont où il ya une primaire
aujourd'hui qui existent en france donc
on change rien ne change rien ou un
processus de rassemblement sur lequel
jean leonetti en train de trier ou après
20 tout simplement les militants de le
dire non au jour rien de tout cela
les militants qui vont dire d'enfants on
essaye de comprendre le 25 c'est qu'on
saura est ce que vous les primaires oui
non voilà et puis si vous voulez une
primaire quel type de primaire c'est à
dire est ce que vous voulez d'un
processus de rassemblement vous voulez
quel candidat on aura cette décision qui
sera presque aujourd'hui c'est dans les
statuts donc étape par étape
le candidat c'est en novembre mais vous
savez faut pas avancer plus vite que la
musique
mais il y en a un qui avance une crise y
en a qui acquiert mes deux pieds
loriette êtes-vous candidat potentiel
que vous avez cité outre chacun pensait
pas que ça les inquiète mais chacun
est libre de son calendrier ses
décisions xavier bertrand a fait un
choix d'autres ne l'ont pas fait est-ce
qu'il faut se déclarer sitôt est-ce
qu'il faut attendre tout va avancer
étape par étape hier à l'unanimité
on a retenu un calendrier en soutien à
ce que l'enfant pose encore une question
puisse y met de la vaccination
obligatoire les clés les militants
disent oui à une primaire
xavier bertrand ne s'y résout toujours
pas les militants réclament une primaire
à ce stade mais maintenant en fait vous
espérer que les militants disent non
comme non mais elle aimait et nos jeunes
mais vous savez si j'ai ri si j'ai
réussi à ce que notre famille soit
apaisée soit rassemblé que l'on gagne
toutes les différences échéances
électorales c'est justement parce que
j'y ai consacré à banon gélard d'aucune
hypothèse l'an passé vous serez alors
donc hypothèse ne s'y résout pas les
militants le vote quand même donc à nos
candidats droite ça et vous avez dit
j'ai bien sûr si on a deux ont peur
c'est très clair et c'est pour ça que
j'appelle les uns et les autres au sens
des responsabilités
il leur dit de toute façon aujourd'hui
la droite est clairement en situation de
gagner la présidentielle
mais si on a deux candidats s'est perdue
avant de commencer françois baroin était
au bureau politique hier soir non il
n'était pas là il pouvait pas être là il
est à l'étranger
vous avez tourné la page définitivement
sa candidature pour 2022 ça c'est une
décision qui lui appartient
il avait bien sûr mais chacun connaît
mais mes amitiés mes affinités mes
préférences mon soutien à françois mais
la décision d'être candidat à la
présidentielle c'est pas votre ami votre
meilleur ami qui la prend pour vous
c'est celui qui est concernée qui laissa
sera lui de le dire
donc il n'a pas encore en tout cas vous
n'avez pas complètement tourné la page
encore un mot pour revenir aux défis
d'aujourd'hui la pandémie évidemment
voit que ça flambe à nouveau
l'air s'est prononcé après la dans le
cadre de la consultation de jean castex
en faveur de la vaccination obligatoire
d'aidés soignants damian matt président
et l'herbe à d'un président et leurs
députés dit il faut se poser la question
pour les enseignants à la rentrée
qu'est ce que ça veut dire moi je pense
que il faut effectivement s'interroger
sur l'ensemble des personnes qui sans
contact avec le public
le risque est trop grave je penche sur
les le personnel soignant pour moi c'est
une évidence
virons peut pas aller dans un hôpital ou
un établissement de santé et attraper la
laque vite parce que ça avait été
transmis par un personnel soignant ça
n'est pas possible et pour toutes les
personnes qui sont en contact avec le
public je pense qu'il faut vraiment se
poser la question aujourd'hui vous allez
dans un département français vous allez
en guyane on vous oblige à voir être
vaccinés contre la fièvre jaune et les
enseignants à votre avis est évidemment
un défi la rentrée de faire en sorte
qu'ils soient vaccinés
je prends ça fait ça fait partie bien
évidemment des gens qui sont en contact
avec le public et je pense qu'il faut
poser tout cela soit on ne peut pas
reprendre le risque de retomber avec une
quatrième vague de retomber dans le club
confinement le blocage de l'économie
les contraintes aux déplacements etc
donc il faut faire preuve aujourd'hui de
responsabilité et la responsabilité
c'est de s'engager
la manière la plus forte et la plus
large possible dans la vaccination
merci beaucoup merci encore d'avoir été
l'invité ce matin de lci on vous
souhaite une bonne journée c'est avoue
marie aline bonjour elisabeth bonjour à
tous